notre invité politique ce matin Éric
Coquerel bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous députés la France insoumise de
la Seine-Saint-Denis président de la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale en étant sans pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Fabrice Bessa Redon bonjour
Oriane bonjour Eric Coquerel un jour
Fabrice du groupe Evra tous les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France on va
bien sûr longuement parler de
l'actualité de la réforme des retraites
mais juste un mot sur l'Ukraine puisque
c'est aussi l'actualité de ce week-end
c'est l'incertitude la confusion autour
de la ville de darkmouth que les Russes
revendiquent avoir pris ce que démon
volodierslinski et ce week-end on a
également appris Joe Biden était
favorable à la livraison par des pays
tiers d'avion F-16 est-ce que la France
pour vous doit livrer des mirages pour
aider les Ukrainiens
déjà il faudrait qu'elle puisse le faire
en termes de moyens ça c'est encore un
autre débat
sont elles-mêmes risquées de s'affaiblir
moi ce que je crois c'est que alors sur
darkmout il faut voir il faut attendre
déjà convenons ensemble que d'abord il y
a un drame c'est une ville qui rasée
nous aimons c'est comme symbolique c'est
plus quelque chose qui peut de
la guerre peut dépendre donc on verra
bien on verra bien la suite moi je crois
que ce G7 a été important parce que il a
réaffirmé comme une solidarité autour
d'une question tout bête le droit
international c'est ça qui doit nous
guider dans cette affaire un pays peut
pas envahir un autre pays et donc à
partir de là les Ukrainiens alors les
moyens de se défendent est-ce que on va
jusqu'à livrer des armes qui sont disons
des armes plus offensives en vue non pas
simplement d'éviter que l'Ukraine perd
et puisse avoir son gardé son intégrité
territoriale mais une victoire sur les
Russes ça c'est un autre sujet et on
sait bien où est le sujet c'est le
risque d'une déflagration mondiale que
personne de censé ne peut ne peut
prendre à la légère donc voilà il faut
trouver le bon équilibre pour permettre
que l'Ukraine ne perde pas que les
Russes et notamment Wagner qu'on a
condamné très fortement de manière
unanime à l'Assemblée il y a peu de
temps ne gagne pas et à partir de là
pour les avions comment oui ou non pour
les avions moi je serai plutôt
aujourd'hui pour avoir une vision un peu
mesurée de ne pas livrer d'avions mais
maintenant je ne suis pas non plus un
technicien d'un conflit je dis
simplement qu'il faut trouver les moyens
pour que l'Ukraine puisse restaurer son
son sa son territoire et d'un autre côté
qui sont construise ce que le Macron a
dit lui-même ce week-end les chances
d'une paix durable je pense que c'est
important qu'ils veulent Macron et
continuer à donner le cap et le cap
c'est restaurer la paix
là le président brésilien renouveau
président
notamment à
volody mirzalinski est-ce qu'il a raison
ce que est-ce que vous comprenez qu'il
préfère ces relations je sais pas j'ai
cru voir là j'ai juste avant que vous me
parliez j'ai regardé un petit peu
rapidement les articles du week-end j'ai
cru voir qu'il est dit regrettait de pas
avoir pu parler à Zelenski donc
manifestement il est à lui aussi a
essayé d'avoir une position
qui est à la fois de de garantir le
droit international mais aussi de ne pas
de ne pas mettre le doigt dans quelque
chose qui serait une généralisation d'un
conflit bon on sait aussi que derrière
ça c'est des visions politiques
différentes
qu'on peut respecter c'est à dire que
du côté du côté de Lula c'est d'une
politique non alignée donc oui au fait
de défendre droite national non en fait
le de pouvoir paraître être dans un bloc
contre un autre bloc et j'admets que
c'est équilibre n'est pas forcément
facile à trouver manifestement en tout
cas ce week-end j'ai cru comprendre que
Lula avait lu aussi soutenu
soutenu l'Ukraine vis-à-vis de la Russie
donc c'est plutôt positif on va parler
de la réforme des retraites le 8 juin
sera donc examiné à l'Assemblée
nationale la conditions de loi du groupe
lutte qui vise à abroger cette réforme
elle est en constitutionnelle a dit
mercredi soir Elizabeth band parce
qu'elle alourdit la charge publique le
président de la commission des finances
que vous êtes n'est pas d'accord avec ça
elle n'est pas constitutionnaliste elle
avait déjà le même avis le gouvernement
elle-même avis il y a pas très longtemps
sur une loi contre le démembre en EDF et
qui rote qui redonnait des prix qui
instauré des prix réglementés de
l'énergie pour les PME pour les artisans
pour les bailleurs sociaux pour les
colitiers etcoriales et moi j'avais
décidé de la déclarer recevable pour des
arguments juridiques que je trouvais
fondés et à l'époque ça a été de la part
de la majorité qui se savait minoritaire
parce que tout le problème de fond est
là il n'en ferait pas des tonnes comme
ça s'il se savait majoritaire à
l'assemblée là aussi on a l'impression
que tout d'un coup c'était c'était la
référence et que je faisais n'importe
quoi pour aller manque de chance au
Sénat quand c'est toi est passé le
président de la commission des finances
du Sénat
le Rapporteur spécial sur la loi Gérard
Longuet qui n'est pas un insoumi ont
tous les deux pour les mêmes raisons que
moi Disney qui a été recevable donc
voilà madame madame borne c'est son avis
je serai elle quand même je resterai un
peu mesuré dans le poids manifestement
de l'exécutif sur le législatif qu'elle
laisse l'assembler se débrouiller sur
cette question je pense que ça serait
mieux démocratiquement surtout pour un
gouvernement qui nous a déjà installé 11
49,3 à chaque fois qu'il est minoritaire
voilà je serai j'aborderai de manière un
peu plus un peu plus humble la période
qui va venir et je laisserai l'assemblée
donc pour qu'on soit bien clair vous ne
déclencherez pas l'article 40 donc c'est
vous pour bien faire moi j'ai pas
déclenché l'article 40 pour que vous
soyez bien clair une proposition de loi
c'est une initiative parlementaire il a
peu dans dans l'année il y a une niche
c'est-à-dire une journée où les groupes
peuvent proposer des lois de 9h à minuit
c'est tout bon et une proposition de loi
elle est elle passe d'abord au bureau de
l'Assemblée le bureau de l'Assemblée ou
la majorité comme vous le savez
majoritaire et le bureau de l'Assemblée
décide de la recevabilité de ses lois y
compris en vertu du fameux article 40
donc de ce point de vue là ça a été fait
et madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
n'a pas voulu revenir là-dessus malgré
ce que lui ont demandé certaines ses
amis bien après il peut y avoir un
recours sur le président de la
commission des finances mais c'est pas
le fait de déclencher c'est pas
automatique c'est à recours que peuvent
décider ou pas certains députés le
gouvernement etc vous savez depuis 2009
depuis que c'est les propositions de loi
de ce type existent et depuis que c'est
le président de la commission des
finances parce qu'il est dans
l'opposition qui décide il y a eu
seulement 28 saisies du président de la
commission des finances et encore
quasiment les trois quarts même plus 90%
ont été faits dans les deux quinquennats
de Sarkozy en depuis on l'a très peu
utilisé tout simplement parce qu'il y a
une espèce de jurisprudence qui veut que
à partir du moment où la proposition est
gagée notamment la fameuse steak de
tabac et bien on laisse l'initiative
parlementaire voilà parce que parce que
il y a un espèce d'É libre je pense que
c'est ce qui devrait être fait et quand
enfin on puisse voter à l'Assemblée
nationale sur cette sur la loi sur les
retraites la bataille politique mais
comment vous justifiez que cette
proposition de loi n'alourdit pas la
charge publique est-ce que le gars
vous verrez bien quelles seront la
décision si je suis saisi il me semble
qu'il y a deux pistes pour aller vite
vous savez qu'on qu'on veut un moment
donné avoir une position sur l'article
40 la jurisprudence qu'est-ce qui a été
fait sur des lois comparables dans les
années passées bon et puis aussi la
compensation il y a des compensations
prévues ces lois je vais regarder dans
sur ces deux éléments si on peut la
juger roswave j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a des pistes pour aller vite la
compensation c'est une taxe tabac c'est
une taxe tabac il y a une conférence
aussi qui est prévue pour la suite
15 milliards mais vous verrez à l'état
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait doubler le
prix du paquet de cigarettes
ça vous savez très bien vous savez très
bien que la taxe tabac est utilisée de
manière j'allais dire commune quand
justement il s'agit de gager même si
effectivement tout ne peut pas répondre
non
seulement
comment vous savez que c'est 15
milliards combien elle est censé
18 après on nous dit 20 on ouvre on
vient à 15h
très franchement ça peut être très
franchement c'est très fort si vous me
le dites parce que si je fais des
calculs si je regarde par exemple selon
l'étude d'impact qui avait été fait
combien rapporté théoriquement les
mesures qui ont été prises c'est-à-dire
17 milliards mais combien elle coûtait
en termes de coût social en termes de
notamment par exemple le fait que vous
aurez plus de personnes qui pourra
atteindre l'âge de la retraite auront
des minima sociaux etc
à une somme de quasiment 9 milliards
vous voyez donc on a des calculs qui
peuvent être très différents ce qui ne
m'étonne pas d'ailleurs parce que comme
cette réforme est très mal fichue qu'en
réalité elle ne règle pas le problème et
bien on a le gouvernement qui nous lance
comme ça des chiffres j'allais dire au
petit bonheur donc je ne sais pas ça
avec une taxe
comme beaucoup de propositions de loi
l'ont été depuis le début où on sait
très bien que la taxe tabac sert à gagé
et qu'après le gouvernement peut lever
le gage c'est quelque chose de
communément admis pour faire en sorte
justement que l'initiative parlementaire
puisse un moment être débattu mais
encore une fois
encore une fois je reviens là-dessus
avant de rentrer dans ce détail il
appartient à la majorité entre
guillemets de décider ou pas si elle
laisse vivre l'initiative parlementaire
je serai elle je réfléchirai deux fois
parce que je crois que ce pays n'en peut
plus d'avoir un parlement qu'il apporte
voter sur le budget 1149-3 pas loin pas
loin de voter sur une proposition loi
sur la réforme des retraites qui allonge
la durée de du travail de deux ans avec
le 49-3 plus un outil législatif qui est
le projet de loi de finance rectificatif
donc vous savez quand normalement il
n'aurait jamais dû être utilisé donc je
crois que ce pays il manque si vous
voulez il a un peu besoin de démocratie
il a un peu besoin que le Parlement sur
ces choses c'est le de nombreux
amendements de la France insoumise qui
empêchait le débat d'avancer la santé
normaux normaux pour une loi de cette
ampleur mais le problème de fait vous le
savez aussi c'est que de toute façon
l'utile l'outil qui avait été utilisé
faisant en sorte que le débat était
tellement réduit qu'on ne pouvait pas
arriver jusqu'au bout donc c'est du
hypocrisie la part du gouvernement qui a
utilisé ça pourquoi pour réduire les
débats et pour éventuellement de pas
voter d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a fini par
se faire et pourquoi pourquoi la
majorité de ne devrait pas elle aussi
déposer des amendements puisque vous
dites que le débat est
nécessairement
je vais revenir si si vous décidez parce
que vous majorité dans sur une niche
parlementaire ou encore une fois chaque
groupe n'a le droit qu'à une journée par
an si vous décidez de faire en sorte que
le débat la loi ne puisse pas être
débattue en déposant des milliers
d'amendements en réalité vous revenez
contre l'initiative parlementaire mais
vous savez pourquoi tout ça est fait
parce que cette majorité n'a pas de
majorité c'est ça son problème à un
moment donné
il y a un moment donné
laissez-moi finir il y a un moment donné
où il faudrait bien d'admettre cet état
de fait et d'arrêter du coup de
contraindre à la fois le pays et
l'Assemblée nationale à des décisions
que ni le pays ni le pays manifestement
l'Assemblée nationale de vol et s'ils
veulent le vérifier et bien qu'il laisse
le débat parlementaire se faire cette
loi est de voter comme ça ça sera au
moins on respirera un peu mieux dans ce
pays qu'en cruel est-ce qu'on n'est pas
dans une impasse est-ce que la bataille
des retraites en réalité elle est pas
déjà perdue et déjà terminé
moi je crois pas je suis pas sûr les
oppositions sont toujours là toujours
mobilisées en tout cas il y a deux
choses il y a les oppositions sociales
et politiques sont toujours là sociales
vous savez depuis je sais pas combien de
mois on nous annonce la fin de la terre
syndicale à l'appel à une grande journée
de mobilisation le 6 et tous les
responsables Laurent Berger compris
préviennent le gouvernement que il ne
faut pas utiliser je ne sais quel
artiste pour faire en sorte que la
propulsion de loi liotte le 8 ne soit
pas voté d'accord donc il y a toujours
une mobilisation forte je vous rappelle
que les décrets ne sont toujours pas
passés que on ne sait pas s'ils arrivent
à passer en septembre donc c'est pour
l'instant elle est pas appliquée et moi
je crois que c'est autant d'espoir pour
vous oui je crois que vous savez je fais
partie d'un d'un milieu professionnel
avant d'être élu qui est la voile de
compétition vous le savez où on dicte
tant que la ligne d'arrivée n'est pas
franchie et bien la course n'est pas
perdue et bien moi j'ai le même point de
vue sur ces lois parce que elle n'est
pas bonne elle ne règle aucun problème
par rapport au régime des retraites mais
par contre elle faut elle force les
Français à travailler deux ans plus et
c'est une fois de plus sur le monde du
travail
à qui qu'on demande de de faire peser
les sacrifices donc pour ces raisons il
faut emmener la bataille jusqu'au bout
et puis on tirera les conclusions après
avant de parler des conclusions est-ce
que vous donnez pas quand même un peu un
faux espoir aux opposants à cette
réforme des retraites en leur faisant
croire que cette réforme sera abrogée et
que ce texte pour aller jusqu'au bout de
reprendre les arguments du gouvernement
là-dessus on entend ça depuis des jours
comment si je suis si demain je gouverne
ce pays que je n'ai pas fait passer
cette loi j'ai pas pu la faire passer
devant l'Assemblée parce que j'avais
peur d'être minoritaire que j'applique à
49-3 et que lorsqu'il y a une
proposition loi d'abrogation elle est
passée je dis que si je continue bike il
y a vraiment après ça sera vous le savez
bien et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le
gouvernement et la majorité enfin la
majorité les parties les groupes
gouvernementaux hésitent éventuellement
à me saisir sur l'article 40 c'est
qu'ils ont peur de la défaite et s'ils
ont peur de la défaite c'est que ça bien
qu'à Lorraine conséquence politique si
cette loi est battu à l'Assemblée je ne
vois pas comment elle s'applique de
manière normale ça sera bien pire de ce
point de vue là que ce à quoi par
exemple Jacques Chirac a eu affaire
quand il s'est opposé aux
CPE excusez-moi avec les anagrammes des
fausses qui n'a pas appliqué parce que
lui a compris au moins qu'on ne faisait
pas un moment donné des lois contre tout
un peuple là sous gouvernement est dans
cette situation si l'assemblée votre
compte j'espère vivement pour la suite
de son quinquennat il ne serait-ce que
ça parce que je vous remarqué que on en
est qu'à un an il reste quatre ans que
il passera il ne passera pas outre le
vote de l'assemblée et puis sinon on
verra ça
partira au cinéma ça revient à
l'Assemblée vous savez qui peut y avoir
plusieurs retours pourquoi pas pourquoi
pourquoi pas forcément
si le Sénat votre contre et bien ça peut
quand même revenir à l'Assemblée après
il peut y avoir une deuxième et là bien
ici une troisième lecture donc il faut
du temps c'est très long c'est très
compliqué oui ça peut ne pas être
compliqué vous savez ce qu'ils sont pas
de conclusif aussi c'est l'application
de cette poids voilà parce que moi je
pense que si la pression sociale par
exemple donne une idée si c'est si c'est
cloises et refusé à l'Assemblée vous
croyez qu'il va se passer quoi au niveau
syndical au niveau social vous croyez
que les ça va pas donner un regain
d'activité de mobilisation moi je le
crois voilà je crois que ce gouvernement
n'en sera de ce point de vue là qu'au
début de ses problèmes et je lui répète
je pense que il ferait bien enfin de
comprendre que sur cette propulsion loi
il est archi minoritaire dans le pays et
qu'il est très certainement minoritaire
à l'Assemblée nationale mais qu'il il le
laisse vérifier le 8 moi c'est ça que je
demande d'accord puisqu'il a l'air de
dire que ça ne se réglera rien c'est pas
très grave mais qu'il le laisse vérifier
au moins respirer un peu mieux moi je
vais vous parler de travail
oui bien sûr les journaux du groupe Ibra
ce matin public va remettre de
l'absentéisme dans les entreprises
un baromètre qui fait apparaître un
niveau record en 2022 du nombre d'arrêt
de travail et de proportions de salariés
absents
avec en tête les troubles psychologiques
comme cause d'arrêt est-ce que selon
vous la France est malade de son travail
la France est malade en tout cas de
faire peser sur les travailleurs la
plupart des sacrifices consentis
notamment après la crise du covid et
depuis des années c'est à dire un sur
les salaires comme vous le savez les
salaires ont augmenté que l'inflation et
ça fait des années que la part des
salaires dans la richesse nationale n'a
cessé diminuer ou profit de tament des
revenus capital et ça c'est un ressenti
parce que ça se traduit en pouvoir
d'achat donc ça c'est un premier
problème et bien payé pour ce que vous
faites et puis la deuxième élément qui
est vous savez cette idée que le
gouvernement utilise sans arrêt c'est à
dire pour gagner plus il faut travailler
plus comme si les Français aujourd'hui
travaillaient pas assez vous savez que
il y a eu un record en termes de
millions d'heures travaillées par par
les Français dans ces derniers temps
donc arrêtons de laisser penser qu'on a
un pays qui ne travaille pas qui pour
s'en sortir devrait travailler plus
comme si on avait affaire des feignants
cette image qui est renvoyée par le
gouvernement cette image qui est
renvoyée aux salariés ça ne donne pas
des j'allais dire une bonne façon à mon
avis d'aborder le travail et là et la
manière de de à la fois mais les
pouvoirs mener de manière conjointe et
une vie au travail et une vie aussi en
dehors du travail auquel on a le droit
parce que la question aussi elle est là
quand vous voulez rallonger de durée de
la retraite de 2 ans quand vous voulez
faire en sorte par exemple de faciliter
les heures supplémentaires pour gagner
plus ça veut dire qu'on vous envoie un
signal c'est qu'on ne peut bien vivre
qu'au travail moi j'assume le fait de
dire qu'on a le droit de travailler
c'est un droit constitutionnel mais on a
aussi le droit à un certain moment
d'avoir des périodes de sa vie ou grâce
à la productivité que tout le monde a
gagné on sait mon site du travail et ça
on n'arrête pas de culpabiliser les gens
là-dessus c'est insupportable et puis
les rapports dans les entreprises sont
pas non plus j'en fais pas du tout une
une vision très très générale mais c'est
pas non plus toujours simple en termes
de de garder son emploi de pression qui
existe par le chômage donc je crois que
tout ça explique les difficultés de nos
salariés ce que vous avez comme chiffre
qui montre bien que le travail
malheureusement
peut aussi être souffrance pour des
millions de personnes un mot sur
l'immigration puisque les républicains
ont présenté hier deux textes pour
durcir la politique migratoire dans
notre pays ils veulent changer la
constitution et il font peser une
pression sur l'exécutif Olivier Marleix
le président de groupe à l'Assemblée dit
qu'il déposera une motion de censure si
jamais le gouvernement tente de faire
passer son texte par 49-3 vous pourriez
la voter cette notion de censure
écoutez le groupe prendra la décision
mais à mon avis si la motion de censure
et son objet et son contenu sont aussi
réactionnaires je ne pense pas que nous
l'avions je vois mal comment on pourrait
justifier on peut voter une notion de
censure pendant deux droites dans le
contenu nous plaît pas mais dans l'objet
est positif mais par contre voter sur un
objet qui serait le durcissement au
corps des politiques des migration de
manière totalement à la fois injuste et
inutile et inefficace non
moi je m'adresse un peu je connais des
gens comme Olivier Marley que je
respecte mais je pense pas que la voix
pour la droite républicaine dans ce pays
soit de toujours vouloir coller à ce qui
est-ce qu'elle imagine être le pignon
public en plus c'est pas forcément vrai
parce qu'au contrairement à ce que dit
la table de JDD quand vous demandez aux
Français vous préoccupations la question
de l'immigration ils ont bien raison
parce que elle est elle est elle est
bien loin derrière les problèmes de
santé les problèmes d'emploi les
problèmes de sécurité etc sauf que quand
française qui a d'autres trop d'immigrés
en France là ils disent oui majoritaire
il y a eu un sondage BVA pour la
Fondation Jean Jaurès 51 % des
sympathisants de la France mais à force
d'avoir des responsables politiques qui
de ce point de vue là disent tout et
n'importe quoi bien évidemment vous
produisez fantasme bizarrement
d'ailleurs vous remarquez une chose
c'est que je remarque en général ce
problème est existe dans des régions de
France des départements de France ou
l'immigration n'est pas très forte bon
tout simplement parce que ce qui rentre
par le poste de télé ce qui rentre par
les certains discours politiques c'est
un espèce de fantasme en gros quand
notamment on est à droite ou même le
gouvernement qu'on a un problème par
exemple sur les retraites sociales on
préfère dire que le problème il
l'immigré c'est plus pratique donc pour
vous en France je vais vous dire une
chose non il y a pas trop d'immigrants
en France et d'ailleurs pour une bonne
raison c'est que vous savez que l'an
dernier ce qui s'est passé on a augmenté
consciemment l'immigrations de travail
pourquoi parce qu'il y a besoin une
immigration de travail dans ce pays donc
disons disons des choses très claires
entre 2000 et 2020 en France de 36% en
plus d'immigrés c'est moitié moins que
la moyenne européenne c'est plus que
moitié moins que ce qui se passe dans le
monde notamment par exemple monsieur le
le trio de responsable de droite qui
s'est exprime hier nous nous dit il faut
arrêter le regroupement familial le
regroupement familial c'est seulement 4
% des titres de séjour qui sont accordés
c'est loin derrière les étudiants le
travail et le refuge donc on est en
train de donner des choses qui laissent
penser qu'on accueillerait toute la
misère du monde alors que c'est loin
d'être le cas et que le problème en
France je vais vous dire surtout il est
un problème de l'accueil voilà il faut
descendre d'accueil disent de son il
faut des cadavres il y a des structures
d'accueil plus importantes il faut
régulariser les trains sans papier qui
le demande en plus à faire des
cotisations pour les retraites et
arrêter d'agiter cette espèce de
fantasme qui j'allais dire et surtout
pour faire en sorte qu'on regarde
ailleurs et qu'on pointe celui qui est à
côté de nous est souvent dans une
situation plus dure que nous comme
l'origine des problèmes ce n'est pas le
cas avant sur la France en chemise et la
nuit pèse et les européennes prochain
grand rendez-vous électoral pour les
Français devant le refus de marine
tondeuillier
pour les européennes d'un accord vous
actez qu'il y aura pas de liste commune
moi je du tout voilà je je pense que si
on veut gagner en 2027
présidentielle législative il pourrait
mieux montrer qu'on est capable d'être
uni dans les élections intermédiaires
avec les écologistes avec les
écologistes puisque pour l'instant c'est
eux qui devient la plus importante
explique qu'ils ne veulent pas le
discommune moi je pense qu'il faut les
convaincre voilà il faut les convaincre
que ensemble on peut être large les
sondages ont l'air de le dire d'ailleurs
on peut être en tête des élections
européennes ce qui évidemment donnera un
peu une dynamique
utile et intéressante pour les élections
à venir voilà je pense que c'est un
travail de conviction moi si je regarde
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée nationale
du peste ça fonctionne bien alors vous
me direz c'est normal puisque c'est le
réacteur de la nuit passée c'est c'est
le résultat de l'accord du statique qui
fait la nuit pêche mais ça fonctionne
bien entre les groupes on veut quasiment
toujours la même chose quand on a des
nuances ou des différents ou légères
bien je vois pas pourquoi on y
arriverait pas pour les européennes je
vous rappelle que sur les européennes
ton autre programme législatif on
s'était entendu sur la triptyque on sort
pas l'Union européenne on est d'accord
pour désobéir au traité qu'on veut
appliquer le programme qui contraire au
traité et puis en même temps on essaie
justement de rompre avec construire
d'autres que l'Europe libérale qu'on
nous offre bon je pense que ça ça peut
fonctionner sur les Européennes et
d'après ce que me disent nos amis
députés on vote à peu près 80% des
textes en commun au Parlement européen
voilà tout ça à mon avis pour aller dans
le bon sens en tout cas moi c'est comme
ça que je cite les 20% c'est pas des
petits sujets c'est ce que disent les
Verts c'est ce que dit notamment
discutons-en discutons-en au monde voilà
c'est ce que nous proposons mettons sur
la table la discussion parce que
globalement être ensemble tous ensemble
serait de la gueule comme on dit voilà
je pense question sur la France
insoumise il y a 300 militants insoumis
qui ont appelé la semaine dernière les
dirigeants de la France insoumise à une
sixième république au sein de la France
insoumise il parle de manque de
démocratie une crise interne liée une
décision verticale à répétition est-ce
qu'il y a un problème de démocratie
je m'en suis toujours fait une une règle
à l'extérieur dans les médias j'en parle
à l'intérieur je dis des choses à dire
il va y avoir un problème vous le dites
à l'intérieur
ce que j'ai pas dit c'est bien essayé
mais j'ai pas dit ça donc nous au moment
où France soumis c'est structuré parce
que c'était important de France
insoumise structure qui était au départ
un mouvement pour des campagnes il y a
eu certaines décisions qui ont été
prises qui normalement devrait être revu
au moment d'une assemblée représentative
en jouant si je me trompe pas on verra
s'il y a des choses qui sont améliorées
par exemple de de passer plus
d'avantages au vote des choses comme ça
qui ont été proposées moi j'ai moi je
pense que on va arriver à trouver des
points d'atterrissage sur les points qui
étaient contestés par certains j'ai pas
lu le texte des 300 peut-être contesté
par les 300 en tout cas je crois que vu
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
on a devoir y arriver voilà on a devoir
de faire en sorte que ça se passe bien
et globalement François soumise moi si
je regarde sur le terrain ça marche les
groupes d'action ça n'a aucun rapport
par exemple avec son AVC en 2018 ou
c'est vrai que le groupe d'action avait
diminué là c'est pas le cas on continue
à avoir du monde qui vient qui milite
donc le reste je pense que les les
autres questions je pense que ça devrait
ça devrait s'arranger merci
Eric Coquerel d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin et merci Fabrice dessert dont
on passe tout de suite au club des
territoires